we need to take a break from the
Republican election fraud disaster in
North Carolina's ninth district which
we've been talking about for the last
week or so to get back to the voter
irregularities in Florida's midterm
elections which we talked about more
like a month ago without rehashing the
entire Florida situation today we
already knew about some of the strange
things that had happened in Florida this
included ballots being held up at a mail
handling facility beyond Election Day
with no real explanation as to why that
happened
The Associated Press can now report that
according to Florida officials thousands
of mailed ballots were simply never
counted because they were delivered too
late and we don't know why they were
delivered too late this is about 7,000
ballots not counted because they were
received after the deadline on Election
Day and the law in Florida is not a
postmarked by law it's a mailed ballots
have to be received by 7:00 p.m. on
Election Day to be counted there's a
lawsuit claiming that they should count
if mailed before Election Day because we
can't explain why they weren't delivered
by the deadline that lawsuit is still
pending
but the question is why weren't they
delivered by 7:00 p.m. on Election Day
given that so many of these were held at
a mail handling facility for reasons
that are as yet unclear to us so we now
have seven thousand ballots not counted
because of this we have another four
thousand mail ballots which were set
aside because election workers who have
no expertise in handwriting analysis
determined that the signatures on the
mailed ballots didn't match comparision
signatures that were on file only six
hundred and thirty seven of those four
thousand ballots were eventually counted
so we're talking about nearly eleven
thousand ballots already without even
getting into all of the other
irregularities so listen would the
results have been different in these
Florida races if these were the only
irregularities these eleven thousand
ballots and all of those ballots went
for the Democrat the answer is no okay
that's not the argument I'm making here
what I'm trying to bring out here is
this is a meta issue where one party the
Democrats have in their platform that we
need to fix our elections and make sure
everybody who wants to vote has their
vote counted the other party Republicans
is breaking the election system
deliberately to help themselves win by
having fewer people vote or maybe a
better way to say it would be by
ensuring that fewer votes are counted
and you know Pat that when Democrats and
Republicans both are guilty of something
I call them both out this is an issue
where the Democrats have in their
platform that they want to fix this
whereas Republicans are using these
techniques to try to win election
surreptitiously and the last place that
this should be happening is Florida
because of the chaos that transpired in
2000 you know shortly after that we did
pass the help America Vote Act which did
some good but that's nearly 20 years old
now and we this absolutely is a meta
issue and we have to solve this for the
next election because otherwise
Democrats are gonna have a tough time
winning and more importantly the will of
the people is not gonna be heard yeah I
know which side I'm on right I support
doing everything we can to ensure more
people vote and that their ballots are
counted I'm against voter purges I don't
want to reduce early voting I don't want
to reduce voting locations
I don't like sketchy ways of
disqualifying non-matching signatures I
don't like letting Russia mess with
elections and not doing a damn thing
about it I know who I support on this
issue it's bad if people don't care it's
going to get worse climate change
campaign finance reform election systems
net neutrality rank-choice voting
Medicare for all it's sounding like a
pretty solid platform for Democrats for
the next few years can they do it can
they actually capitalize on it I wish I
was more optimistic